well hello I love seeing you two
together it brings me like the most Joy
okay so in this cast who would make the
best detective in real life
um I would say Kate Hudson
everyone keeps saying that I know yeah
because it's the truth well because
we've all played that game Mafia with
you and you are so good but I think
you're an amazing BS detector what's
really interesting is that I don't think
anybody in ever would think that you
guys would all say me especially based
on the character I play in this movie I
know but that's why it's so awesome
because it's unexpected and off because
of the character you play in this movie
but she really is an amazing BS she has
an amazing BS detector and also her
she's incredible at this game Mafia like
so good I would say that you would be
really great at it but you probably get
you probably want to like yeah you
probably want to like do something else
yes you'd be like a kind of over trying
to figure out what's going on if I had
to yeah oh you're I would do it but if
it was a game
it's a wrap yeah I think Edward would
Edward would be an interesting detective
it probably would just take a couple
years to get something you know because
he's very thorough yeah
um and I think Leslie would be a good
one yeah Leslie would be
yeah yeah I heard you were very
competitive Edward made a joke that you
and your fiance after a game that you
guys played might need therapy he was
like I am questioning you were so on
everyone they were like was I on Danny I
was on one of the games I think I was I
was like oh you are that's right because
I was sitting across from Danny and you
know it's kind of I but it's like
cheating you know when you're with
someone you know especially my man who's
like the purest most wonderful kindest
person when he's not telling the truth
like he gets a little flushed I like
news immediately so you know I had to
take him down yeah you know seriously
her hands were tied I had to do it for
the town she had to um
who would you not want to commit a crime
with because they can't keep a secret
well I wouldn't want to commit a crime
with you because we just laughed we
wouldn't be able to no we would not
be able to pull it off we'd end up back
at the rescue no right
right exactly we're gonna commit a crime
first let's stop at the outlets
a mess
it's a mess
I love it here I love it here I love it
here
um in a real life game of Clue like why
am I doing things
start the car
um who in a real-life game of Clue would
be the best at it and the worst at it um
in a real life game clue of clue
variables I'm not I'm getting out I'm if
the stakes are high I'm getting out
alive because I know all my exits yeah
and I will I will take I will take them
down yeah see that's why she's so good
I'm like I don't even know there's so
many variables I'm like do I grab the
candle do I grab
I don't know who I am yeah maybe you
would be the worst
I know what do you mean by the exits I'm
like I don't even know where I am
I haven't rolled my dice yet okay I know
all my exits and the most effective
that's why I would still be like is it
my turn
thank you ladies